he hablado un montón de como el cambio
en la energía interna de un sistema
puede ser debido a alguna inyección de
calor al sistema o algún trabajo que
realice el sistema o que realicemos
sobre el sistema y vamos a escribirlo
también de la otra forma que el cambio
de la energía interna es igual al calor
que agregamos al sistema menos el
trabajo hecho por el sistema entonces
hay dos cosas que pueden brincar te de
la cabeza que como es que el calor se
puede agregar al sistema y cómo es que
un sistema puede realizar trabajo o
podemos realizar para el sistema verdad
entonces vamos a hacer un poquito más
precisos en este en este en este caso de
lo que estamos hablando y digamos que
tenemos un sistema aquí digamos con un
buen de partículas aquí adentro digamos
este es un cilindro que estamos viendo
por enfrente y está a cierta temperatura
no sé cuál digamos a una temperatura de
uno de hecho pues no sé vamos a decir
que son 300 grados
elvin por ejemplo ok 300 kelvin y
queremos agregar calor a este sistema
entonces lo que puedo hacer es poner
otro sistema junto a él
justo pegado a él
quién sabe de qué tamaño es esto pero
tiene partículas aquí adentro su
temperatura vamos a suponer que es mucho
mucho mucho más grande que la del
sistema original digamos que digamos la
la temperatura de este sistema es igual
a 1000 grados que el vino se solo estoy
inventando números pero qué es lo que va
a pasar en esta situación vamos a tener
que se transmite que se transmite calor
de este sistema rosa albert de verdad
ahora el calor y el trabajo y la energía
interna esto esto nos regresa a la
conversión de los macro estados versus
los microestados verdad el calor está
cambiando el sistema está perdiendo
temperatura el sistema rosa y se lo está
transmitiendo al sistema verde entonces
estas moléculas van a perder energía
cinética y los del verdes lo van a ganar
que es lo que está pasando realmente
bueno vamos a suponer que tenemos aquí
en medio digamos esta es una es una
pared sólida de estas moléculas empiezan
a chocar sobre el muro y éste empieza a
vibrar más verdad entonces cuando las
moléculas del lado verde se tocan esa
parte del muro entonces empiezan a
rebotar con mucha más energía cinética
con más velocidad debido a la vibración
que hay en este muro así que
esencialmente así es como se transmite
la energía cinética o el calor y creo
que es bastante intuitivo si ponemos
esto va a enfriar digamos un sistema con
menor temperatura entonces perdemos
energía cinética
porque entonces esto puede ser por
compresión es no voy a tocar mucho de
eso ahorita pero como podemos agregar o
restar trabajo a un sistema y ahorita
vamos a regresar a nuestro ejemplo del
pistón
ok déjenme dibujar algunas líneas aquí
entonces digamos que este es mi
contenedor ahí lo tienen y que tenemos
un techo movedizo de ese es mi pistón y
vamos a volver a este ejemplo verdad
porque lo que vamos a estar tratando es
presión y volumen en un diagrama baja
que quiero tratar con procesos cuasi
estáticos procesos que siempre están
cerca al equilibrio que podemos pensar
que los macro estados como la presión y
el volumen están bien definidos verdad
entonces hicimos varios ejemplos medio
locos de un sistema que lo pasamos a
flujos y perdían la definición de
presión y volumen entonces vamos a
suponer que tengo canicas acá arriba o
piedritas digamos y que tengo cierta
presión así que digamos que mi pistón se
mantiene fijo por esas rocas que están
ejerciendo una presión hacia abajo y el
gas que está contenido está empujando
todo hacia arriba entonces la presión
ha definido porque está en equilibrio
ahora qué pasa en el ejemplo cuando
quito uno de estas de estas canicas
vamos a quitar una de estas canicas son
estas piedras déjenme copiar y pegar ok
vamos a copiar y pegar esta cosa de aquí
copiar y pegar muy bien ahí está el
mismo sistema y ahora vamos a remover
una roca vamos a quitar esta de acá
arriba esta piedrita que es lo que va a
pasar bueno ahora tenemos menos peso que
está empujando empujando al pistón hacia
abajo y tenemos una cantidad de presión
menor el sistema temporalmente se va a
salir de su equilibrio pero en
diferencias muy pequeñas y muy lentas
verdad entonces este sí no es un cambio
muy grande en el equilibrio podemos
permanecer cerca de él y sabemos del
ejemplo anterior que esto se va a mover
un poco hacia arriba entonces esto se
mueve un poco hacia arriba muy bien y
déjenme rellenar lo otro con negro
porque no este no ha desaparecido este
espacio
sólo vamos a rellenarlo un poquito aquí
así que nuestro pistón se mueve un poco
arriba una cantidad muy pequeña y lo que
afirmo es que cuando removí en la canica
de aquí el sistema hizo cierto trabajo y
vamos a pensar acerca de esto así que el
trabajo de acuerdo con nuestras
definiciones que hemos aprendido en
física
cuando usamos por ejemplo mecánica
clásica sabemos que el trabajo es igual
a la fuerza por la distancia
ok pero sea por distancia entonces
afirmó que el pistón se movió arriba
pero debido a que quitamos una de las
canicas se generó un trabajo entonces
estoy suponiendo que estoy afirmando que
se hizo un trabajo porque el pistón se
movió cierta distancia entonces vamos a
tratar de ver qué es lo que pasó aquí
utilizando otras macro macro variables
apropiadas y lo que sí sabemos es que es
la presión que se ejerce en el pistón al
menos en este punto del tiempo tenemos
que la presión es igual a la fuerza
entre el área el área del pistón verdad
porque aquí aquí el pistón bueno no es
una línea sino en realidad es como un
plato plano o un techo plano y bueno qué
distancia se movió digamos
si esto se movió esta distancia de que
digamos que es x fue lo que se recorrió
el pistón
entonces este cambio fue fue la
distancia x que se desplazó el plato el
techo sale entonces cuál es la fuerza
que que se ejerció sabemos que la
presión es igual la fuerza entre áreas y
que podemos despejar podemos despejar
multiplicando a ambos lados por área
y obtenemos la fuerza verdad así que
esencialmente estamos diciendo que el
área de este techo del contenedor podría
ser no sé éste
no sé pero tiene un área verdad que es
probablemente igual que el área de la
base de la lata y esto ejerció una
fuerza es decir que la fuerza fue igual
a la presión
la presión por el área del techo del
pistón ok ok entonces ahora esa es la
fuerza ahora cuál es la distancia la
distancia desde aquí es x no sé así la
llamamos la distancia es déjenme ponerlo
en azul este cambio no lo dice muy
grande pero bueno ese es x y ahora
déjenme ver si puedo relacionar esto de
alguna forma déjenme dibujar esto un
poquito más grande así que vamos a
dibujar otra vez el pistón qué color lo
hice ok vamos a dejarlo así entonces
nuestro padre nuestro pistón digamos
puede ser como algo de forma no sé como
una elipse se movió hacia arriba a una
distancia x de ejemplo no este no me
dejen déjenme copio y pego este
así que el pistón digamos lo empujamos
hacia arriba a una distancia x déjenme
dibujar eso
lo empujé a una distancia x
y estamos afirmando que oh perdón aquí
me equivoqué en la fórmula verdad esto
es la fuerza de esto y esta es la
distancia así que el trabajo es igual a
la fuerza que es presión por área
presión por área es la fuerza y luego
multiplicamos por la distancia verdad
quiero dejar claro esto que la fuerza es
esta presión por área y luego
multiplicamos por equis para obtener el
trabajo entonces este es el área del
pistón digamos que tiene forma de elipse
en este caso entonces la presión por el
área ahí tenemos la fuerza y se movió
una distancia x se movía una distancia x
verdad entonces vamos a a podemos
regular esto digamos podemos decir que
el trabajo expresión x
área por equis que es área por equis el
área es digamos esta área por equis en
realidad lo que estamos obteniendo es un
cambio en el volumen verdad esta área
por una altura es un volumen y
esencialmente es que tanto cambio de
volumen nuestro contenedor cuando
empujamos hacia arriba el pistón verdad
el volumen incremento y pueden ver
digamos que el rectángulo
el rectángulo se hizo más alto verdad
tenemos cierta área que la desplazamos x
una distancia de xy que por lo tanto nos
da un cambio en el volumen así que
podemos escribir que el trabajo en
términos de otras cosas que conocemos
por ejemplo que el trabajo hecho por el
sistema es igual a la presión por el
cambio en el volumen
también el volumen
ahora esto tiene una repercusión muy
interesante aquí verdad porque de
podemos de chop déjenme reescribir la
fórmula del cambio de la energía interna
en termino de esto tenemos que el cambio
en la energía interna es igual al calor
agregado al sistema más el trabajo
digamos más bien menos el trabajo hecho
por el sistema entonces cuál es el
trabajo hecho por el sistema pues es la
presión por el cambio en el volumen
verdad en este caso se expandió en este
caso el sistema está empujando las
canicas las piedritas digamos hacia
arriba está realizando un trabajo si
estudiamos haciéndolo en la otra forma
digamos poniéndole piedritas entonces el
pistón se empuja hacia abajo y le
estamos imprimiendo un trabajo al
sistema ok
esencialmente el gas está empujando
hacia arriba el pistón y por lo tanto el
sistema está realizando un trabajo si
volvemos a nuestra fórmula de el cambio
de la energía el calor
- el trabajo hecho por el sistema
entonces podemos reescribir esto como el
calor agregado al sistema
el calor agregado - la presión la
presión por el cambio en el volumen y es
interesante que si el cambio está
incrementando el sistema está realizando
trabajo y esto aplica sobre todo por
ejemplo en algunas máquinas que veremos
en en otros vídeos que hacen una pequeña
explosión hace que un cilindro empiece a
empujar un pistón y entonces empieza a
generar otras cosas que que ya veremos
en otros vídeos pero el punto es que
hace un trabajo entonces los dejo ahí
con este vídeo en el próximo vamos a
relacionar esto estas nuevas formas de
escribir la energía interna y vamos a
relacionarlos con el diagrama presión
volumen